ce
[Musique]
ne soit pas dans ces deux parties pour
cela vraiment j'ai décidé c'est un non
sens mais des artistes qui partagent des
murs univers à travers de larges
extraits
[Musique]
l'orangerie c'est un lieu absolument
magnifique parce que ce n'est ni un
musée ni une galerie mais c'est ouvert à
tous tous ceux qui veulent venir
chercher un petit peu de curiosité un
petit peu d'art après avoir déambulé
dans le jardin venir chercher un peu les
créatures des hommes et prendre
conscience qu'il se passe tout un tas de
choses non seulement au sénat mais dans
la vie en général
aujourd'hui je suis très heureuse de
pouvoir participer en tant qu artiste
franco argentine dans un endroit aussi
magnifique aussi important pour
l'arachide au sénat c'est un lieu
extraordinaire il ya ce volume
fantastique et cette lumière
merveilleuse qui vient caresser les
oeuvres et qui vient les magnifier et a
énormément de monde qui vient ils ont
besoin de comprendre ils veulent savoir
ce que c'est donc il ya un vrai échange
et ils sont hyper touché et je trouve ça
chouette de mettre tout ça à la portée
de tout le monde c'est un des rôles du
sénat de mener cette politique
événementielle qui permet de mettre en
avant des artistes des artistes de tous
ordres que ce soit des sculpteurs des
photographes ou des peintres et de
permettre au plus grand nombre de
profiter de leurs oeuvres
[Musique]